All right. We're going to do a couple more definitions. This
notion of a version space turns out to be really important
in understanding how to analyze these algorithms. So, imagine we've got
some hypothesis, space H, capital H. And a true hypothesis that we're
trying to learn, C of H. This is also sometimes called
a concept. And we're trying to learn from a training set
S, which is a subset of the possible inputs. And what
our training set consists of is those examples along with the true
class for all of those X's. So, at
any given time a learner might have some candidate
hypothesis, little H and big H, and a learner
who produces a candidate hypothesis little H, such that
C of X is equal to H of X for all X of the training set, is
called a consistent learner. Right, so what would be
another way of describing hat a consistent learner is?
>> A consistent learner can actually
learn the hypothesis, or the true concept.
>> Well it produces, right, I mean of all the possible things it could
return, it returns the one that matches the data that it's seen so far.
>> Right, so it's consistent with the data. That makes sense.
>> Yeah. And the version space is essentially the space of all the hypotheses
that are like that, that are consistent with the data. So we'll say the
version space for a given set of data S is going to be the
set of hypotheses, that are in the
hypothesis set, such that they're consistent with respect
to the samples that they're given.
>> Okay that makes sense.
>> All right. Good. So I think what we'll do next is a quiz just to make
sure that we kind of get this concept and
how it works. And we'll do that next time.
>> Okay sure. I like quizzes.